- [Voiceover] So let's
go ahead and work through
an actual curl computation.
Let's say our vector valued function V,
which is a function of X, Y, and Z,
this is gonna be three-dimensional,
is defined by the functions, I don't know,
let's say the first
component is X times Y.
The second one is
cosine of Z,
and then the last component
is Z squared plus Y.
Let's say.
So if you take this guy,
how do you compute the curl
of that vector valued function?
So what you do, as I
mentioned in the last video,
is you imagine taking this del operator
and taking the cross product between that
and your vector valued function.
And what that means when you expand it
is that del operator,
you just kinda fill it
with partial differential
operators, you could say,
but really it's just the
symbol partial partial X,
partial partial Y,
partial partial Z.
And these are things that are just waiting
to take in some kind of function.
So we're gonna take the
cross product between that
and the function that
we have defined here.
So I'm gonna just actually copy it over,
copy it over here.
And a little residue.
And to compute this cross product,
we take a certain determinant.
So I'm gonna write over here determinant,
and it's gonna be of a
three-by-three matrix,
but really it's kinda like
a quote-unquote matrix,
because each component
has something funky.
So the top row, just like we would have
with any other cross
product that we're computing
is gonna have i, j, and
k, these unit vectors
in three-dimensional space.
And the second row here is gonna have
all of these partial
differential operators,
since that's the first
vector in our cross product.
So that's partial partial X,
partial partial Y,
and again, all of these are just kind of
waiting to be given a function
that they can take the derivative of.
And then that third row is gonna be
the functions that we have.
So the first component here is XY,
the second component is cosine of Z,
cosine of Z,
and then that final component
is Z squared plus Y.
Z squared
plus Y.
Now let's all get some room here,
maybe make it more visible.
So this is the determinant
we need to compute.
And this is gonna be broken
up into three different parts.
The first one,
we take this top part, i,
and multiply it by the
determinant of this sub-matrix.
So when we do that, this sub-determinant,
we're taking partial
derivative with respect to Y
of Z squared plus Y.
Now as far as Y is concerned,
Z looks like a constant.
So Z squared is a constant,
and the partial derivative of
this entire guy is just one.
So that'll look like one.
And then we're subtracting
off the partial derivative
with respect to Z of cosine of Z,
and that just looks the
same as a derivative
of cosine Z, which is negative sine,
so that's negative sine
of Z.
So that's the first part.
And then as the next
part, we're gonna take j,
but we're subtracting, 'cause
you're always kinda thinking
plus, minus, plus, when you're
doing these determinants.
So we're gonna subtract off j,
multiplied by its own
little sub-determinant,
and this time the
sub-determinant is gonna involve
the two columns that it's not part of.
So you're imagining this first column
and this second column as
being part of a matrix.
So the first thing you do is you take
this partial derivative with respect to X
of Z squared plus Y.
Well no Xs show up there, right?
That's Z squared and Y.
Each look like constants
as far as X is concerned.
So that's zero.
Then we take the partial with respect to Z
of X times Y.
And again, there's no
Z that shows up there,
so that's also zero, so we're
kinda subtracting off zero.
And then finally, we're
adding this last component.
We're gonna add that last component, k,
multiplied by the determinant
of this sub-matrix
of the columns that it's not part of.
So this involves partial derivative
with respect to X of cosine Z.
Well no Xs show up there,
so that's just zero.
So that's just a zero.
And then we're subtracting off the partial
with respect to Y of X times Y.
Well X looks like a constant,
Y looks like the variable,
so that partial derivative is just X.
So we're subtracting off X.
Which means if we simplify this,
so the curl of our vector field,
curl of our vector field as a whole,
as this function of X, Y, and Z,
is equal to,
and that first component, the i component,
we've got one minus negative sine of Z,
so minus minus sine of Z.
That's one plus
sine of Z.
And then the j component,
we're subtracting off,
but it's zero.
Usually if you're subtracting off,
you'd have to make sure
to remember to flip those,
but both of those are zero, so
the entire j component here,
or the Y component of the output, is zero.
And then finally, the k
component is zero minus X,
so that entire thing is just negative X.
And that's the curl of the function.
And in general, that's how you do it.
You would take a look at the way
that your function is defined
in each component there,
and imaging taking the cross product
between this del symbol,
this partial partial X,
partial partial Y, partial partial Z,
and you take the cross product
between that and your function,
and it involves taking six
different partial derivatives.
And mainly it's a matter of bookkeeping
to make sure you do it right.
And you'll end up with
something like this.